Film Courage: Well I like how you say you
watch DRIFTER (that’s who you were at that
time) and maybe whether it makes you uncomfortable
or not, you see who you were, what you were
going through and what you were trying to
get the audience to feel.
And you can see that with bands (let’s say
U2), their first two albums very angry and
raw (excellent albums) but different from
newer ones where life is maybe a little better,
money is little more plentiful and so people
are in a different state of mind.
But I get it, I was watching this talk show
with Wes Craven and I think it was from 1988
and it had some of the commercials still playing
[in the Youtube video] and this was from a
talk show that I watched as a little girl
and it was like “Wow?
Even the tone of the commercials were more
upbeat?
The music, everything.”
So the tonality of the world was different
then.
We reflect what we see.
So in 2015, people had come out of the recession.
It was a tough time for everyone especially
millennials because jobs were not, you could
have felt that.
It was an angry time for a lot of people.
Chris von Hoffmann, Horror Writer/Director:
I think I was just open to exposing the ugliness
of humanity.
The flip side of things like Bret Easton Ellis.
When he wrote THE RULES OF ATTRACTION and
AMERICAN PSYCHO and all of these kind of things.
He was much more attracted to the flaws of
people.
And I think the one thing that I’m very
attracted to is kind of like a common thing
that no matter how mainstream I would want
to dabble in.
I am very interested in very flawed people
and very flawed characters against even more
flawed characters.
Sort of like a somewhat cynical outlook on
the world but in a fun, exciting way.
Not in a witty kind of entertaining kind of
way.
But I think I’m getting better at approaching
it with the same kind of intention but I mean
lighter is not the best word but a little
more audience friendly but still having that
same kind of outlook.
Because I don’t want to loose that kind
of outlook because I think that’s what make
my kind of stuff specific, something a little
more like my mom would enjoy.
DRIFTER is not her kind of movie.
It’s just not her kind of movie.
Film Courage: With DRIFTER I’m not sure
if you’re able to talk about the budget?
I was curious how you did the location scouting
because you talked about the desert.
And how you were very intrigued by the desert.
I know the desert has always intrigued me.
There is something frightening about it and
then something mysterious and etherial about
it because you can kind of get lost in there
and there are all these interesting drifters
(there really are and you kind of wonder what
their background is).
What is it about the desert and how did you
find the location?
Chris: Well we shot the movie for like $40,000.
But I’d shot a couple shorts in the Lancaster
area/Palmdale so I was a little familiar with
that area.
And DRIFTER was the first time I really embraced
my fascination with the desert because I had
been really fascinated with it for a couple
of years because I love stories about isolation.
You know just getting old before your time
and just burning so much gas money just driving
to the outskirts because there was no location
manager or anything.
It was a very skeleton crew.
But the kicking off point was that my cinematographer
had known about the town that was in Bombay
Beach.
BAD MATCH with Keanu Reeves shot there a few
years ago, they had wrapped filming a few
months before we had arrived.
But I think mostly they do photoshoots and
commercials there and they don’t do that
many features (maybe they are starting to).
But that was the kicking off point to write
a story around that town and then drive around
all over the place trying to find something.
It was actually really…since there was no
location manager that movie is so much driven
by the set pieces, the locations were paramount
in that story.
If the location didn’t fit, that movie was
going to get laughed off the screen and I’ve
seen a lot of micro-budget, post-apocalyptic
stories shooting in Vasquez Rocks in Valencia
[a popular LA County attraction] and you see
tourists in the background.
I want to shoot in places that no one shoots
in, forbidden places.
Film Courage: Devil’s Punchbowl.
Chris: Yeah.
I wanted to go to Death Valley but it was
way too far.
So just finding these different places and
we were in pre-production for a long time.
It was a very small crew so I need time to
get all that stuff.
And the locations were probably the most major
thing because you don’t want to break the
bank but you want to make sure that the locations
are as cinematic as you can get.
So a lot of negotiating and shooting and random
spots all over the place.
But it was mainly all around Lancaster, Joshua
Tree, Bombay Beach, Victorville.
We shot a little in LA inside this haunted
house, only enough right around the corner
from where I lived.
I’d been trying to find that location since
forever and I would go in all these houses
that were normal houses.
I was trying to look for a haunted manor,
TALES FROM THE CRYPT kind of house.
And I was shocked that we were able to get
the house that we got because the guy was
just this super nice guy and hooked us up
on a great deal with it.
I just get so obsessive because I love locations,
I love the bigger the better.
And seeing this house that was right around
the corner, right around my nose the entire
time and it literally had everything we needed.
All the rooms they had extra furniture, literally
everything we needed was there.
It was very odd, almost like destiny.
But locations, that’s one of the things
that I’ve very stubborn about in pre-production
because it dictates the quality of the movie
and I’ve seen films with really crappy locations
and I’m just like “Why would you ever
use that?”
You’ve got to be realistic at a certain
point.
But I think there’s a difference between
being realistic and settling.
You want to make sure you can get the best
location you can possibly get.
And I think a lot of people are just like
“That’s okay.
Let’s just shoot there.
We’ll just shoot around it.”
Locations are so, so important.
If you’re making a cinematic story, they
are very, very important.
It just dictates so many things.
Film Courage: How did you deal with the wind
and the heat?
And also too I don’t know how close were
any stores, so how were you dealing with the
remote location and the elements?
Chris: We shot two filming blocks in July
and August 2015 and in July we were shooting
a lot of night stuff in the Lancaster/Victorville
area and it was freezing.
One girl she was covered in fake blood for
hours that night and she was shivering (her
teeth were chattering the entire time).
It was rough but that was nothing compared
to when we shot in the town because the Film
Commission, they were like laughing at us
because we were shooting in August.
Even that other movie that I was talking about,
they filmed in April and even then it’s
hot out there and it doesn’t start to cool
until October.
We could push until October.
I wasn’t going to be one of these guys who
shoots on the weekend and months later shoots
again.
I’m too impatient for that.
And so in the thick of August, literally the
worst time you were supposed to be shooting
there.
I remember we were so cautious if we could
afford a medic there because we needed a medic
to come about and we were nervous if we could
afford it.
And then we finally did get one to come out
and there were a couple moments where people
almost passed out.
And it was very intense.
I’d never felt heat like that before.
I remember when we first arrived, everyone
was having a great time driving out there.
And the moment we first arrived people couldn’t
breathe when we stepped out of the car because
the moment we arrived we went right into filming
and people were already feeling it.
And we had four more much more ambitious days
after that.
I think the hottest it got was 120 [degrees]
and it was the biggest day that it was the
hottest (the most ambitious day).
But I think looking back at it, I think it
dictated people’s performances.
I think it really…freezing cold and scorching
heat I think it really influenced people’s
performances because all that sweat is all
real.
The sunburn and all of that, all of it is
I just love the stories of the original TEXAS
CHAINSAW MASSACRE, scorching heat and such
a nasty atmosphere and locations they were
filming in so that you don’t want to touch
anything.
You look at the film and it lends itself very
well to it.